et cette soirée d'hier aura décidément
été riche en surprises puisque à gauche
elle a été marquée également par
l'annoncé de la séparation de ségolène
royal et de françois hollande
une annonce qui intervient alors que
l'ex candidate affiche désormais ses
ambitions de conquête du parti
socialiste alexandre kara fabien tormos
ainsi priver puisque désormais
l'information et public entre ségolène
royal et françois hollande
c'est la rupture une situation nouvelle
révélée par l'ex candidate socialiste
aux auteurs de ce livre les coulisses
d'une défaite est confirmée de vive voix
dans la matinée c'est vrai que j'ai
proposé à françois de vivre sa vie de
son côté
et qui l'a acceptée donc cette cette
séparation et de fait nous ne sommes
plus au même domicile séparation
confirmé devant les caméras par françois
hollande
nous avons fait en sorte de mener notre
combat l'un et l'autre l'un avec l'autre
l'un pour l'autre
en tout cas moi je les fais et après il
ya la vie personnelle et elle ne doit
pas avoir d'interférence
la révélation de cette rupture en pleine
soirée électorale fait un peu désordre
dans les rangs du p c'est pas des façons
de faire y compris pour notre premier
secrétaire les questions de personnes
sont non pas secondaire du tout mais
secondes ce qui est important ce sont
les questions de fond même tonalité dans
cette section socialiste du gard
je suis pas ce pas que ce soit d'une
importance cruciale pour le pays et que
bon ça ne nous regarde pas voilà je
trouve que c'est un moyen peu
particulier de lancer le débat d'idées
au parti socialiste il faut que tout ça
devient un peu trop people dans un
exercice de clarification un peu tardive
ségolène royal se défend de tout calcul
politique
je n'ai fait hier aucune déclaration et
je pense que si cette information est
sortie hier
ça n'est pas un hasard et je regrette ce
type de méthode
d'autant que la rupture privés
pourraient s'ajouter rapidement une
rupture politique ségolène royal ne s'en
cache pas son intention est bien de
prendre la direction du ps en lieu et
place de françois hollande 7